without question one of the most
important issues we Sabbath Day
Adventist need to understand is the
relationship of Ellen White's writings
to the
Bible so many Adventists miss that
boat and there's a major campaign
against 7eventh day adventism and Ellen
White and one of the charges is that we
raise Ellen White to the level of the
Bible and that's one of the areas I
specialize in is responding to the
critics or criticisms of Ellen White so
I want to address the topic of Ellen
White and the Bible tonight you'll
notice there uh you'll see the Bible
right here and the writings of Ellen
White it's important to understand that
her writings chronologically
chronologically come after the Bible so
I want to talk about that issue but
first let's look at a key passage
Revelation
1217 this is a key text for Adventist a
key text in the Bible if you read the
book of Revelation it comes to a climax
a shindo and Apex and the center of it
is chapters 12 13 and 14 and chapter 12
is an amazing chapter in in the Bible in
the Book of Revelation it it gives the
cosmic sweep sweep of church history
with the crucifixion of Christ and the
war in heaven and they overcame the
devil and his angels through the blood
of Jesus and it comes to the persecution
of God's Church down Through the Ages
all the way to the end of time
and Revelation 12:17 reads and the
dragon was wroth with the woman and went
to make war with the remnant of her seed
which keep the Commandments of God and
have the testimony of Jesus Christ so
here we have the characteristics of
God's people at the end of time now you
know what the dragon represents what
Satan and the woman represents the
church and the remnant
represents the last part
that's the meaning of the term the last
part a sewing term the last piece The
Remnant God's people at the end of time
and they are characterized two ways two
characteristics they keep the
Commandments of God and they have the
testimony of Jesus Christ and if you
look at the context of the passage in
chapter 11 John sees the temple of God
open he sees the Ark of the Covenant in
heaven that provides the parameters for
interpreting the rest of it so when he
mentions the Commandments of God here
he's not just talking about as some say
the New Testament commandments of Jesus
it certainly includes that but he's
specifically talking about what is in
the Ark of the Covenant which is none
other than the decalogue the ten
commandments so when he says these
people keep the Commandments of God he's
talking about the Ten
Commandments but what is interesting as
the Commandments of God are in a
parallel form with the testimony of
Jesus Christ now that phrase testimony
of Jesus Christ is the second
characteristic of God God's people it
says they have that testimony they have
the testimony of Jesus Christ now this
phrase testimony of Jesus Christ is
important to John he refers to it
several more times in the book what
exactly is it well if you just look at
the phrase by itself in the original
Greek New Testament the testimony of
Jesus it could be interpreted two ways a
testimony about Jesus or a testimony
coming from Jesus
if it's a testimony about Jesus then it
could be then a testimony that
every person of the remnant has Jesus
loves me this I know for the Bible tells
me so let me tell you my testimony about
Jesus but it could also be interpreted a
testimony coming from Jesus if it's
interpreted that way it's a prophetic
message from
Jesus a self-revelation of
Jesus which way do we interpret it you
look at the phrase in its context and in
the immediate context the testimony of
Jesus Christ is in a parallel connection
or parallel relationship with the
Commandments of God it's very clear that
the Commandments come from God don't
they they originate from God he spoke
the 10 commandments and since it's in a
parallel form then the testimony of
Jesus must be interpreted as a testimony
issuing forth from Jesus coming from
Jesus
therefore we can see right in its
immediate context that God God's people
are those who keep the Commandments of
God and they possess a prophetic word
from Jesus a self Revelation from Jesus
a prophetic message from Jesus now some
say well that if it's that if that is
the case then the testimony coming from
Jesus is what's found in the
gospels Jesus word in the gospels the
gospels contain the teaching of Jesus
that came from Jesus and certainly it
would include that wouldn't it but the
way John uses this phrase later on
provides greater Clarity and make and
greater Clarity I should say he makes it
abundantly and explicitly clear that
this testimony is more than just what
Jesus said in the Gospels it is
something he says
prophetically at the end of time it's a
special self-revelation of Jesus to this
Remnant living at the end of Earth's
history
well good evening thank you for being
here and an especially warm welcome if
this is your first time with us
Adventist or otherwise so what we heard
there was from a part of a lecture that
SDA religion Professor Dr Jud Lake gave
a couple years back that was titled uh
Ellen White's Legacy as a prophet Dr
lake is no stranger to this platform I
am a former student of his and he has
responded to some of the criticisms that
I've raised albeit in my opinion
insufficient ly but we got to hear the
integral role that Ellen White plays
within adventism despite a lot of the
Neo Adventist crowd trying to downplay
her distance themselves from her Etc
what Dr Lake explained is the larger
role that she plays in the Adventist
edifice she's supposed to help identify
the SDA Church as God's special last day
people The Remnant that the rest of us
are supposed to come join if we want to
be prepared for the second coming AKA if
want to be saved put in another way Dr
Lake explained how the SDA Church
teaches that Ellen White was an inspired
prophet of God and Revelation 12:17 is
supposed to help prove such Jesus is
allegedly speaking through her writings
in a special and unique way identifying
the Seventh Day Adventist movement as
God's end times people possessing this
special testimony from Jesus this
prophetic word but if this is falsified
then the ripple effect of that or at
least one of them is that they're not
the remnant and that collapses and we
don't actually need to come join them
our souls are not in danger but rather
according to scripture Mark and avoid
this sect and seek to reach Adventists
with the
truth now in his book Ellen White Under
Fire identifying the mistakes of her
critics Dr Lake writes the following
quote the nature of inspiration is a
major underlying issue in the debate on
Ellen
White all detractors and supporters of
her prophetic Ministry either
knowingly or unknowingly presuppose a
view of
inspiration if that view is too rigid or
too loose then chances are strong that
those who hold that view will
misunderstand undermine or even discard
Ellen White's writings the same is true
of the Bible an incorrect view of how
inspiration worked in the prophets can
beog the biblical message close quote
so this is a common starting point that
one is going to run into regarding
defenses of Ellen White's authenticity
as an inspired Prophet the claim being
that if you understand inspiration
properly you'll be able to see that
Ellen White was indeed a legitimate
Prophet it's only if you have a what Dr
Lake calls a real rigid understanding of
inspiration that you'll come to a
conclusion that Ellen White doesn't fit
the bill so we are going to discuss the
subject of inspiration tonight examining
some statements in Dr Lake's book and
then we will test Ellen White and see if
she fits the bill for what lake and the
SDA Church Claim about her and
thankfully I have the perfect guest to
help us
out who is Step Boyce Steven Boyce has
been here before but Dr Boyce is the
founder of the facts podcast which
primarily focuses on the church fathers
the apocryphal works the Canon and text
of scripture and scriptural exag Jesus
he holds a PhD in the area of Canon and
text from Louis and a Baptist
Theological Seminary and his main study
was on the Gnostic texts and the
canonical gospel his dissertation
covered textual analysis of codex H
which included the early patristic
writings that contained readings from
the
septuagenarian Anglican apologist he has
also pastored in two churches and helped
three Church plants across the United
States but quickly before we bring him
in as well one last housekeeping thing
I want to remind you all that if you
like what we're doing here and you want
to partner with us you can do so at
answering adventism
docomo our mission is to equip as many
Christians as possible to reach as many
seventh day Adventists as possible with
the true Christ and his gospel and it is
through the support of our partners that
we are able to do that so A major major
thank you to all of our partners and
YouTube members with that said Dr Boyce
thank you for being here brother what
did you think of that intro clip and the
handling of Revelation 12:17
oh man uh so so many thoughts on
Revelation 12 as as a whole because he
jumped into verse 17 which is the very
end of the vision the vision begins in
chapter 11 and there's so much that has
to be established in this apocalyptic
Vision before we even get to that he
wrongly identified the woman number one
uh number two his application of the
testimony of Christ by spending so much
time on the Gena of noun because you
have the ASU there at the end if I'm not
mistaken Nea Sue is genitive so it's a
it's a term of possession of Christ from
Christ and he made a big deal about that
which sounded really Technical and cool
but it really doesn't change anything in
how it's translated of Christ is
sufficient the word testimony is a term
uh that most of the time in the Book of
Revelation is used and can be related to
where we get the word martyr a person
who's a witness a testifier it's it's
where we get the word martyr from um so
how did John use that word all the way
before uh he used it there in chapter 12
see these are things that I jumped on
immediately and said okay there's a lot
of faulty exog Jesus already happening
in chapter 12 here because he's not
practicing how the word testimony is
used all throughout because Jesus
actually used the word out of his own
mouth to the churches in uh Asia Minor
earlier in the book and he talks about
their testimony their their martyrdoms
he does use it in multiple ways and then
how he understood the woman in the
passage is quite fascinating very very
off from early interpretations of the
Book of Revelation so I I think that
when you start your premise with a
presupposed interpretation that doesn't
do the diligent work of actually
breaking it down uh he would find that
his view of the woman there is in a very
very small minority on being the church
because he said it's the church when
most would interpret the woman to be
either two to three things number one a
restored and glorified Israel uh
producing the child or some would go on
to say that it even represents a twofold
in that it is Israel but
specifically the woman being Mary and we
could possibly get into that uh I think
anybody that reads that would think Mary
or the third possibility that the
terminology that is used here goes back
to a Genesis 3 prediction the seed of
the woman so this vision is supposed to
make us go back to Genesis 3 it's
supposed to take us even in Genesis uh
34 all the way into 40 where Joseph and
and dreams and visions and then the 12
stars look at the description around
there this is stuff that you see in
Genesis and exodus language even Isaiah
refers to Israel as the woman uh or or
Lamentations Jeremiah refers to the city
of Zion as the woman um you have the
seed of the woman you have the uh the
the building of that through the prophet
so there's a lot there that most
Scholars would land on as the
interpretation because in his
interpretation of the word
church it's he's saying that the church
produced Jesus ultimately if the woman
is the church the church produced Jesus
when that's not the case Jesus said I
will build my church the church was
produced by Jesus not the other way
around so it's already built on a faulty
ex Jesus just in Revelation 12 and I can
go on I could do a whole lecture on
Revelation 12 by itself and how to
interpret it back in chapter 11 but I
don't think that's the point of the
program well no but that that's good I I
think that that's important um sort of
backdrop information especially for the
audience because as you heard a lot of
this sort of foundational um framework
for these claims about her divinely
inspired status are rooted in and he
even mentioned it this is a very
important verse he said for Seventh
Avenue
and so this is exactly why because this
is one of their primary places that
they're going to point to to begin
trying to lay the biblical framework or
or Baseline for the legitimacy of Ellen
White so to break the ice I want to do a
little bit of groundwork for both you as
well as the audience and then I'm gonna
have my first question for you sure so
I've shown this before I don't know how
many times but let the record bear out
that in the sth Adventist Church's
statement of confidence in the writings
of white they write in part that her
writings are divinely inspired and
correcting of inaccurate interpretations
of
scripture the same thing was taught for
example in the 1976 Sabbath School
quarterly where they write quote how
advantaged the Seventh Adventist Church
is to have a modern inspired interpreter
of both the Old and New Testaments
surely there is every logical reason to
give the inspired interpretation top
priority in arriving at our
understanding of the word today close
close quote so very clearly my point
with this is they claim that LG white
was indeed inspired but like I read in
the opening from Dr Lake what do they
mean by
inspired he writes quote in contrast to
the community and encounter models which
place inspiration in either a community
or a non-cognitive relational encounter
the thought model places inspiration in
the biblical writer's thoughts
the spirit of God works by directing the
writer to the thoughts or concepts and
allowing the writer's own distinctive
personality to come into play in the
choice of words and
expressions in thus emphasizing the
biblical writer's freedom to express the
Divine thoughts inum words this model
departs from the verbal plenary and
dictation models since the time when
Ellen White's 1886 manuscript on
inspiration was published in the
selected messages book one the thought
model of inspiration has become mo more
influential in the Adventist Church
close
quote he also posits the standard SDA
position that there are not degrees of
inspiration which is to say her writings
are inspired no differently than the
Bible and then Ellen White herself
saying the Holy Spirit authored both her
writings and the Bible which is why Dr
Lake shouldn't be surprised when people
point out that the SDA church and Ellen
White herself put her writings on par
with the Bible so the point is when the
SDA Church says Ellen White was inspired
they are claiming that she had inspired
thoughts the Holy Spirit directed her
thoughts and she used her own words to
try and best convey those thoughts from
God and this is supposed to be what
happened to the biblical writers as well
so Stephen what does it mean that the
Bible is inspired and are we able to
deduce the correct model of inspiration
from the scriptures
themselves yeah I think the scripture
has a lot to say about itself more than
we have opinions of because it
ultimately is not a hidden agenda within
scripture as as far as how it reveals
its Essence uh when we look at the word
inspired most people uh think biblically
of second Timothy where it says that all
scripture is given by theonas God
breathed that's what it means um there
are ancient debates about what those two
terms theas so God and then Nas breathe
or or breath in of itself when God
issues it out of his mouth uh we we even
see in say example Peter's writings
Peter talks about how men of God were
moved by the Holy
Spirit and and then there was going to
be special remembrance I mean we see
this even in John 14 when Jesus says
that he is going to leave and that he is
sending another comforter the paraclet
and when the paraclet comes he will
guide them into all truth but then he
tells them that when that Spirit comes
to them they're going to be given
Supernatural remembrance of things that
he said because they're humans they're
gonna they're going to forget so when
Jesus himself was telling the apostles
you're going to receive the spirit of
God who's going to bring back
remembrance of things that I said things
that I did and you're going to tell
others that was not just mere thought
this is the mistake that was made in the
interpretation that inspiration is based
merely on some sort of thought or or an
idea of inspiration is interpretational
or subjective to somebody's perspective
that's not the way the scripture teaches
it Jesus was entrusting his teachings
his words to his Apostles that the holy
Spirit would bring back those words to
their remembrance and this is what we we
even see lay out later on in the
scriptures in the New Testament as it
develops with the apostles writing
they're going back they're thinking on
what Jesus said they're thinking on the
interpretation of those things and
they're they're laying it out and saying
that the Holy Spirit moved them to do it
I mean even when you go to the Old
Testament for example like in Jeremiah n
Jesus said or God said to him I have put
my words in your mouth
I put my words in your mouth so the
proclamation that Jeremiah gave about
the Babylonian captivity coming the
repentance of sin all of those things
were God's mind the things that God
wanted to say and used a human agent to
do so so that that person personality
educational background we don't believe
in this perspective of inspiration where
where the writers become you know in a
trans or something like that they're
sitting there and you know doing
mushrooms or something and that they're
just flowing out the words of God no no
there's an intentionality behind it that
God has moved them by his Spirit to
produce with the hand of men the very
words on the heart of God and so when
God told Jeremiah I have put my words in
your mouth he is literally speaking as
the Oracle of God he is the mouthpiece
of God at that point so the writers of
scriptures and those who proclaimed the
very truths of God are speaking the
exact words in their personality in
their background in their voice
structure uh in their language the way
that God would have said it to that
original audience or wrote it to that
original audience so that they are
reflecting the very words that God had
so when we go through scripture and you
don't have to go even further than the
Psalms and even in the Proverbs you know
these are the words the words that I
give to you the Commandments that I give
to you they're not Concepts they are
exact words they're verbal words um and
they were spoken at times they were
written at times they were spoken then
written and we even see the the dynamic
of this say like in the book of Jeremiah
since I mentioned him earlier God gave a
proclamation he wanted King zayah and
others to know I'm giving you a last
chance if you ignore my words I'm going
to actually bring the Babylonians in
you're going to become enslaved to them
and he's going to destroy and steal
everything they're going to take
everything from you well I mean when you
get the false prophets in and you look
at the advisors to the king they chop up
the letter that was given well what does
God do oh no I only spoke once I can't
reproduce this no he brings Jeremiah
back and he gives him not only the same
words again that were produced in the
first letter but additional Clauses of
judgment for rejecting and doing what
that did the first weather letter so God
reproduced and
inspired uh Jeremiah to be able to
produce something exactly the same way
twice without being able to copy another
copy because God is the one who's behind
it but it is still a human agent who is
fully within his mind his emotions his
feelings we see this in scripture the
personality of The Writers come into
play one of the most amazing things if
you go in the original languages you say
look at the book of uh Galatians for
example you start looking at the verbs
that Paul uses and and the tense that he
is in using those verbs he's animated
he's mad he's upset he's confused you
can feel the emotion of the writer in
the book of Galatians but you can also
feel the love and adoration that he has
in other writings like his writing to
First Timothy uh or second Timothy and
treating him like a son you can see the
love or even in the small little letter
of phiman that I've had to translate
multiple times in comparison to the
Pastoral Epistles and its syntax when
you look at their Lang with the language
of Paul there you can sense an endearing
and and a a quiet Soul who is just
thinking deeply about somebody and who
is fully embracing a relationship
Galatians it's it's fireworks I mean
he's he's angry he's mad the personality
and even the emotion of the writer is
still in the text but they are moved in
step with God in his emotion and his
feeling so that there's this community
between God and man who are not one or
the other scripture is not all God and
no man it is not just man and no God it
is God and man in harmony where the Holy
Spirit promised by John 14 gives those
who he authorized authority over these
texts authority over these churches to
be moved to do things that in their
natural Instinct would not but the
spirit still uses their instinctive uh
attitude and emotions and disposition to
write exactly what God would say to them
and that is what we see through the
scripture we have no Pro I mean I love
how how Paul tells the Corinthians like
this isn't a commandment for me this is
a commandment for the Lord what is he
doing he's saying I'm speaking for God
that's what Paul is saying I'm not this
isn't my opinion I'm telling you what
God is telling you and when he's writing
First Corinthians he believes he is
speaking on behalf of God uh Peter
believed that when Paul wrote letters
they were speaking on behalf of God and
equal to other scriptures like Torah uh
when he quotes scripture and when he
talks about how those are in the church
corrupting scripture he speaks at the
very end of second Peter chapter 3 how
they how they manipulate and how they
have tainted scripture and all the
writings of Paul and he puts scripture
and the writings of Paul in the same
category of equal Clauses described by
the word scripture saying that these
scriptures and Paul's scriptures are all
scripture and they're all from God and
they're equal because he believed that
God moved Paul to write the very words
not Concepts the words of God the same
way that Moses was conveying to the
children of Israel the words of God or
the prophets like Jeremiah the very
words of God that he said I will put my
words in your mouth we see no hint of
this view of inspiration in the old or
in the New Testament as it relates to
the teaching of inspiration but the word
inspiration itself is only used one time
in the way that Paul uses it two Greek
words put together the anas god breathed
he moved words out of his mouth when you
speak breath comes out of your mouth God
moved words not Concepts words so the
very word inspiration itself indicates
to us God uttered words out of his mouth
and that's Hebrews 1:1 um many times in
many ways here it is God spoke to the
prophets Theos lasos God uttered words
that's exactly what that word means
these are the concepts of scripture that
we see in scripture about itself it is
not simply conceptual or visual or
ideas well we're going to see in a
little bit how they have now kind of
built upon this model because they've
recognized some of the s obviously since
the 19th century to the present day that
this presents and they've built upon
that but before we get there we saw how
Lake mentioned a statement from Ellen
White in the book selected
messages now ironically folks this is a
statement well this is the statement
that he's referring to and it's a
statement that was plagiarized and taken
from Calvin stow's book origin and
history of the books of the Bible both
the canonical and apocryphal where he
wrote quote it is not the words of the
Bible that were inspired
it is not the thoughts of the Bible that
were inspired it is the men who wrote
the Bible that were inspired inspiration
acts not on the man's words not on the
man's thoughts but on the man himself so
that he by his own spontaneity under the
impulse of the Holy Ghost conceives
certain thoughts and gives utterance to
them in certain words both the words and
the thoughts receiving the peculiar
impress of the mind close quote so that
was published in 1867
Ellen White's manuscript that selected
messages ended up citing from was
written 19 years later in 1886 where she
wrote quote it's not the words of the
Bible that are inspired but the men that
were inspired inspiration acts not on
the man's words or his Expressions but
on the man himself who under the
influence of the Holy Ghost is imbued
with thoughts but the words and thoughts
receive the impress of the individual
mind close quote and this is only one of
the many examples that she stole from
the same book now the defense to these
stolen words and ideas is this Lake
gives the standard SDA rejoiner where he
writes quote over the years the
mechanical view of inspiration that
persisted in the church talking about
the Seventh Adventist Church was a
ticking Time Bomb Herbert Douglas
described the situation when it is not
made clear for Generations that profits
do change with personal growth that
prophets do use other sources for
bringing precision and force into their
messages
rigid Minds there's that word again
rigid rigid Minds experience a
terrifying Awakening when the truth is
brought forth Assurance built on Words
and not the central message begins to
collapse for in the years since 1982 the
time bomb has exploded many church
members have lost confidence in Ellen
White's prophetic gift because of the
charge that she copied from other
authors those with a mechanical view of
inspir a have a hard time handling the
idea of inspired authors using the
writings of others to express their
inspired thoughts but for those with a
more holistic view of inspiration the
issue of plagiarism is considered from
other uh standpoints such as intent fair
use quality of selectivity and ultimate
originality of the author's
contribution close
quote so Dr Boyce scholarship within the
SDA Church claims that Ellen White's
plagiarism does not call into question
her her uh writings being inspired
because the biblical writers themselves
engaged in the same practice that she
did they took thoughts ideas and words
from others when Penning the scriptures
so why can't Ellen White that's
basically the argument their thought
model of inspiration allows for a person
to take the thoughts ideas and words of
another individual who wasn't inspired
use them as their own but slightly
modify them and still rightly claimed
that the plagiarist was divinely
inspired so my question for you what
would be the method for testing the
inspiration of a writer or document and
does plagiarism call into question Ellen
White being
inspired well for one plagiarism in the
ancient world is not considered
plagiarism uh what we call plagiarism
they didn't have that concept uh people
borrowed from each other all the time
was very common it wasn't it was
actually flattery more than an insult
today plagiarism isn't I'm not promoting
plagiarism by any stretch I'm saying we
in the ancient world plagiarism was not
seen the way that we look at it today we
see it as stealing somebody else's work
somebody else in the ancient world would
have seen more of that as flattery so
let's just go ahead and settle that from
the beginning at the same time um in the
ancient world there is a developmental
thought again let's take Revelation CH
12 because it's been brought up by our
friend here Revelation 12 you look at
the vision of the woman with 12 Stars
well that's stolen from Genesis
37 uh well then she's pregnant and in
child pain well that that's stolen from
Genesis
3 and then you have the the vision of
the Dragon oh that that's stolen from
Isaiah well then you have the devouring
of that dragon the the dragon trying to
Devour the child well that's stolen from
Exodus that's stolen from the Gospel of
Luke you know we could do this all day
the reality is is most of the time when
the the biblical writers are alluding
back to an already previous statement
they're watching how God has developed
it in history which is exactly what John
is doing in the apocalypse there in
chapter 12 he is seeing the consummation
of multiple prophecies in Israel's
history from Genesis 3 to Genesis 37 to
Isaiah chapter 7 uh all the way into the
New Testament covenants when we see uh
the birth of Christ
himself when we see the fall of Satan
himself all of these things come into
play and John is seeing the full end of
this prophecy how it has developed and
come to its final consummation that's a
plagiar and that's
stealing um that is quoting and I know
they're going to use examples they're
going to use examples like my
with Isaiah hey quick thought did it
ever occur to you there in the same
timeline and that Isaiah had a school of
the prophets and that he was trained in
the school of the prophets and Prophets
who are Disciples of another Prophet
like Elisha to Elijah or like John the
Baptist and his disciples or Jesus and
his disciples their job is to repeat the
teachings of their teacher like hey
there's an idea um so when they use
examples and they try to do this they
try to get themselves out of this well
well th this minor Prophet is quoting
Isaiah over here well yeah because he's
in the discipleship program if you would
of the school of the prophets and Isaiah
had a school of the prophets we see it
early in Isaiah so naturally you know
what the students are supposed to be
doing they are teaching their teachers
teachings because that's what Jesus
taught his disciples to do that's what
John the Baptist's disciples were
teaching them them to do that is the
very standard of ritical teaching and
prophetic teaching Ministries in Israel
and the ancient near East it's a
plagiarizing it's actually professing
what was taught to you and repeating it
that's why Daniel at the beginning of
Daniel for example looks back at
Jeremiah's prophecy he is a plar he
quotes and says he told us this is what
happened nobody listen and look here
this is the reality of it he is a
disciple he is watching he's learning
he's a student of the prophets and he is
gaining Insight from what they said and
now they're looking at it down the road
going this has been brought to the end
this is true what was said was true uh
proved over and over again so the
examples they use and pardon me they are
just lame they are lame because it shows
and reflects that they do not understand
what it means to teach or to Proclaim or
to write things that happen and things
that were said in an ancient neare
Eastern context T this is normal in our
day and age it is not normal it is
stealing that's what it is here's
another thing about you asked about uh
inspiration her you know Len versus say
John or or Paul or Peter the difference
is that these individuals are authorized
personnels they are given what was
needed to create
theonas I mean let's look at some
examples and I and I gave you one in
John 14 just a minute
ago but it was explicit people that were
called to this so in second Peter
chapter
1 verses 20- 21 knowing first of all
that no prophecy of scripture comes from
someone's own interpretation well that
debunks most of everything we just read
so far up to this point it's not based
on an interpretational
inspiration prophecy wasn't given by a
private interpretation
for no prophecy was ever produced by the
will of man but men spoke keywords spoke
from God there's that genitive he was
talking about in Revelation 12 spoke
from
God as they were carried Along by the
Holy Spirit the question then is who
gets carried Along by the Holy Spirit
who is permitted well we
know we know Hebrews 1:1 God
spoke at many times and in many ways in
the past to our fathers by the prophets
the prophets were the mouthpiece of God
we even see this in the book of
Zechariah in the Old Testament that God
only reveals his secrets we see this in
Amos we see this in Zechariah 1 God only
reveals his Secrets or God only speaks
through His
prophets and this idea that it is the
people that are Inspire not the words is
ridiculous because there are code laws
that protect the words more than the
writer if you were to go to the end of
the book Deuteronomy there's a
description of whoever adds to or takes
away from what was written will be
cursed well isn't ironic that in the
same book that was just butchered a few
minutes ago in Revelation you go to the
very end of the book of Revelation and
you have these words in 20 22: 18-19
I warn everyone who hears the words of
the prophecy of this book if anyone adds
to them God will add to him the plagues
described in this book if anyone takes
away from the words of the book of this
prophecy God will take away his part in
the tree of life and the holy city which
are described in this book there are
code law curses attached to the Torah
into the end of the Canon that if you
add not to the person to the the words
of the book you are given plagues and
curses for corrupting manipulating and
twisting the
words so yeah it's the words because the
code laws are protecting the words in
the
prophecies and God only authorized
prophets to be his mouthpiece that's how
he spoke to the fathers in the past in
these last days he has spoken to us by
his son
now to our knowledge and to our
abilities we don't know of any documents
that Jesus wrote save maybe one letter
Jesus sent to a a pagan King who was
sick who needed healing that's another
story for another day whether or not
it's true or did happen um it is an
intriguing one I did an entire episode
on it but outside of that we don't have
any teachings of Jesus we we don't have
any teachings that he actually wrote
Because we see Matthew 28 we see in Acts
chapter 1 we see in the passage I
referenced earlier John 14 that all
scripture was going to be given out all
of his Commandments all of his teachings
all of his Works were going to be
proclaimed by those he authorized in the
past God authorized prophets in the last
days God spoke through his son and he
authorized them his Apostles to be the
very people who Proclaim what they heard
what they learned what they
saw and they were the mouthpiece and
this is exactly how the writer of
Hebrews later understood this in chapter
two he said how should we neglect so
great a Salvation which began to be
spoken by the Lord and those who heard
them that had been revealed to us the
writer of Hebrews is even imagining like
it is them those apostles who heard the
Lord who have proclaimed these teachings
to us we see Jude learning back second
Peter saying the the apostles warned you
they they told you this what happened
and it's going to happen it saw it as
predictive it saw them as authorities
who are the authorities it's not Ellen
White Ellen White's way too gone it had
to be eyewitnesses of Jesus who are
authorized by Jesus who were given
special insight and privilege from the
Holy Spirit John 14 that nobody alive
today has and nobody since the year 100
has had the ability to do and only
scripture that is on behalf of God as
Peter said earlier in the verse that I
read men spoke from God can only be from
people who actually heard God and the
only people that actually heard God were
the prophets in the past and those who
heard God In the Flesh himself the
apostles who are authorized and special
privileged with the spirit to bring back
Supernatural in remembrance to teach and
understand his words he left with them
to share in the world so that
disqualifies everybody today there is no
inspiration today we can be inspired in
the sense of built up or or given
Insight or understanding and we start
speaking from that that's not the same
thing as inspiration that we're talking
about the way the scripture speaks of
itself lots of good meat there um a
couple things that I just think about in
this particular aspect of this
discussion um one is also the apostles
didn't take from others and then
copyright those things and make a modern
day equivalent of millions of dollars um
but then the second is it's mildly
ironic that we heard Lake mention in the
opening clip Revelation 127 is supposed
to help us identify the SDA church is
God's last day Remnant and the two
reasons given they have a special
testimony from Jesus in Ellen White's
writings but the second is because they
keep the Ten Commandments um yet Ellen
White a co-founder and their prophetess
was stealing from others violating the
sixth commandment and was then passing
it off as coming from God violating the
third command
which is bearing God's name falsely so
just a little bit of irony there but
something else I want us to look
at in a letter defending her role as
God's messenger Ellen White claimed that
her mind was never prejudiced by anyone
else and if it was then she wasn't fit
for the work of being God's messenger so
this was in a letter that she wrote to
someone that was inquiring about the SDA
Church fitting the bill for their own
definition of Babylon which they
basically claim is doctrinal confusion
and division it is Roman Catholicism and
her daughters the Protestants um
and part of what's supposed to
distinguish them from such is that they
have the spirit of Prophecy this
testimony of Jesus Jesus spe you know
especially speaking through Ellen
White's writings exactly like we heard
from Jud Lake well this statement is
supposed to be divinely inspired so
here's a bit of a catch 22 here she
borrowed thoughts words and ideas from
others took them as her own claiming
they were inspired by God yet at the
same time she claimed her mind was never
prejudiced by anyone because if it were
she wasn't actually an inspired
messenger of God that issue aside Dr
Lake presents a pretty standard defense
you're going to hear where the Bible is
said to have been the result of the same
practices Ellen White engaged in we've
already touched on this a little bit but
he's going to go into it further here
piggybacking off of what he said earlier
quote the biblical writers borrowed from
each other and even from some uninspired
writings
examples abound throughout the Bible
Moses borrowed from the ancient NE
Eastern world in the structure of
Deuteronomy and Micah bored from Isaiah
The Scribe who compiled Second Kings
also Drew from Isaiah in Ecclesiastes 12
99-10 Solomon states that he borrowed
Proverbs from Wise sages and
Incorporated them into his book Proverbs
close quote then he ends this chapter a
few pages later where he notes that it
is a well-known fact that Ellen White
used other writers um writings but that
doesn't negate her prophetic inspiration
he
says so this is probably the most common
defense to the claim that Ellen White's
plagiarism disqualifies her from being a
divinely inspired Prophet they'll say
the biblical writers did the same thing
she's just in line with them so if you
attack her writings you need to be
consistent and also attack the Bible
Stephen what are your thoughts on this
defense and again did the biblical
writers take words thoughts and ideas
from others claim they came from God and
then copyright those writings and make a
large sum of generational wealth off of
them well no they actually put their
lives at risk most of the time when they
were doing that it didn't give them
money it gave them actually a Target um
again I I answered this earlier quite in
depth so I'll just give quick summary of
this like Micah to Isaiah they're
they're they're not borrowing from them
they are instructed under their
teachings now he uses other examples and
one of the things that we have to keep
in mind when we're talking about
inspiration is that we we've fault in
false ways come to this conclusion oh
all truth can be found in scripture and
that's the only place we go for truth no
all truth is God's
truth um all things that are in our
world have the Fingerprints of God in it
when you look at creation the heavens
declare the glory of God the firmament
shows his handywork day and Day atter
speech not in tonight shows a knowledge
there is no speech nor language where
their voice is not heard I mean you go
through that and you see that the
Fingerprints of God are everywhere which
means he leaves evidence of truth of
himself in history in science in
archaeology um you you look at it in the
world that he created he left evidence
of himself everywhere and to think that
Christians are the only ones that can
find this or at the time the Jews are
the only ones that can discover this is
faulty um yes Moses was trained in all
the ways of the Egyptians Stephen said
in Acts thinking back on
Moses which means not everything he
learned in Egypt was
wrong he learned pattern he learned
style he learned language uh he probably
learned how to do uh elements of oratory
and and even thinking about the
afterlife and death of course he was in
inuenced by all these things but not
everything that he learned was fult
there were true things in the false
that's why we find a lot of the biblical
writers using books like the Assumption
of Moses like in the book of Jude or
first Enoch second Peter and Jude uh you
do see books of Asher uh or J jasher
excuse me and you do see
other just non canonical books or
influences coming into the New Testament
you see Paul doing this he quotes uh
philosophers he quotes poetry uh people
from the island of Cree we see them
using this why because what they came to
realize is that all of these things that
they learned in the universe is that
God's truth can be spoken by fools and
by wise men and that even truth can be
spoken from the mouth of babes and at
times there's something that said that
may not be from a Christian or a Jew
Jewish follower of Yahweh that receives
or understands or or or finds wisdom or
truth in the world it doesn't mean that
they have the trademark of Truth so by
somebody looking back at that other
person who is doing something or saying
something true like Paul talking about
um on the island of cre that the
Christians are are are fat and and full
of lies and all these things and he says
this testimony is true so don't be that
right so Paul is acknowledging a truth
that came out of a Pagan's mouth and
says and since that is true so what does
that mean that means that they have the
concept of
superintendent that that when they are
looking at the evidence whether it's a
scientific or a historical or or
narrative or some sort of concept when
the biblical writers are looking at
other documents statements philosophers
poets the holy spirit of God is giving
them superintendence to know what is
true and what is not true to include in
their points or in their statements or
in their narratives of scripture see
that's the difference inspiration is not
creating only truth inspiration is
giving specific truth that can come from
anywhere else in the world where there's
a lot of untruths and nontruth and
finding the real truth in the world and
producing it under inspiration so that
people have absolute truth and so when
you look at scripture itself we say it
is the word of Truth uh sanctify them
through through your word for your word
is truth Jesus prayed your word is truth
God's word is truth but God's word is
not just found from uh sitting in a room
and writing it down sometimes it could
be a person investigating the world
investigating the universe investigating
something that happened and says that
part is true but it was the Holy Spirit
that gave them the ability to know the
difference between false and Truth Ellen
White doesn't have that Ellen White
wasn't promised that Ellen White wasn't
given that because Ellen White wasn't
with Jesus Ellen White was not an
eyewitness Ellen White was not given
Authority by Christ himself to testify
of Truth and to Proclaim truth and we
see this because even Jesus later in his
high Priestly prayer praying for us down
the road prays that we would be one as
he and the father are one but then he
talks about the
words that he gave to his disciples and
those that believe their words that's us
that believe the testimony of the
Apostles well whose words are the
apostles words I thought they got them
from Jesus they did where did Jesus get
his words that which I speak is what the
father has given to me oh so those are
God's words himself so God gave his
words through Jesus Jesus gave his words
to the apostles and we believe them
because of that Jesus prayed
intercessory for us because we chose to
believe the words of the Apostles one
problem with modern day prophets and
inspired people none of them were under
the authority of Jesus who were prayed
for in that Garden to have his words and
to have their words believed on by us
the people so none of us can be that
second category Jesus spoke to the
apostles Theo Apostles gave us his words
we believe their words as a result
believing his if we are the third party
we can't be the second party and nobody
in the third party is the second party
and Ellen White is not in the second
party because she and none of the other
people and none of these and he and and
all these other guys that we're talking
about here are not in that category of
truth because they weren't with Jesus
they weren't authorized by Jesus they
weren't promised the Holy Spirit the way
that we were I'm not saying we don't
have the Holy Spirit I'm talking about
the way that they had special
remembrance of his M of his ministry
because none of us were they T need like
we need remembrance of a Ministry we
were never a part of and never seen
doubtful very
doubtful again a lot of good meat there
um something that I think is just
interesting that I think about with this
defense is um it's kind of similar to
the claims made by Skeptics of the Bible
who will assert things you know like oh
the story of Noah is actually
plagiarized from the Epic of Gilgamesh
um those sorts of things except those
folks say that to try and refute the
biblical text SDA case they're employing
a similar thing only trying to use it to
bolster Ellen White just an interesting
observation yeah those are Mystic and I
always say similar similar isn't same
just just say yeah so Dr Lake actually
proposes a second theory I mentioned
this earlier a second theory of
inspiration that they call the whole
person model it's leges charged that
this is now the predominant view in the
Adventist
mainstream though as the handbook of 7th
Day Adventist theology notes the SDA
Church doesn't have an official position
technically Dr Van bmlin writes quote in
1874 GI Butler then serving as general
conference president proposed in a
series of articles in the Advent review
in Sabbath Herald a theory of degrees of
inspiration this concept though for a
short time enjoying some popularity did
not find permanent acceptance among
seventh day Adventists neither did the
concept of verbal or mechanical
inspiration while concepts of plenary
and thought inspiration have been widely
favored the church has never formulated
a precise doctrine of inspiration nor of
Revelation through more than 100 years
however Adventists have reiterated and
elaborated the convictions held by their
Pioneers in various statements of
fundamental beliefs close quote so
really the official position is what the
Pioneers believed because it has to be a
theory that can account for Ellen White
being legitimate or they lose their
unique identity as the remnant which is
why thought inspiration is where they
land and any sort of theory that doesn't
allow for plagiarism and errors is seen
as being too
rigid however like I said there is a
second model that modern SDA scholarship
has come up with speaking about this
model DR Lake writes quote because of
the problems associated with the thought
model of inspiration after carefully
studying scripture and Ellen White's
writings
several Adventist theologians have
discovered a broader view of
inspiration several terms have been used
to describe it entire inspiration
comprehensive inspiration historical
cognitive inspiration the biblical model
and whole person inspiration the term
proposed here this model of inspiration
goes a step further than the thought
model recognizing that while the uh that
while the words of scripture weren't the
primary focus of the process of
inspiration it did reach the words of
the biblical writers however not in the
same sense taught in the verbal plenary
or dictation models Norman Gully who is
an SDA Theologian who has since passed
described this model of inspiration this
way the prophet's freedom to write was
the same as their freedom to speak the
messages God was guiding them in the
writing process as he guided them in the
speaking process process the prophets
were filled with the god breathing power
of the Holy Spirit and wrote or spoke
Faithfully all that God communicated to
them but the prophets were not in a
trance operating like a fact or
dictation machine they were not speaking
in tongues or uttering incomprehensible
incomprehensible gibberish they were
participating in the process of
inspiration the mind of each Prophet was
fully in operation as the Holy Spirit
gave them freedom to write or to speak
the cognitive linguistic logical powers
of the prophets were under inspiration
from the spirit of as God worked through
their free use of these Powers the
spirit guided the prophets to express
truths in the best language logic
Aesthetics and words the prophet could
muster close
quote he then again the end of the
chapter he ends it by stating quote the
model that best explains the variety of
the modes of inspiration we find in the
Bible is the whole person model it
accounts for the inspired writers using
the best words they could muster to
express the Divine
Concepts even when these words came from
sources that were not divinely inspired
of the six models discussed in this
chapter therefore the whole person model
best sets forth the phenomenon of
inspiration as found in the Bible close
quote so modern Adventist Scholars by
reading the Bible and studying Ellen
White's writing
I didn't know if you I don't know if you
know this Stephen but they discovered a
new model of inspiration a sort of
modified thought inspired view that
they've come up with where they say the
words are kind of inspired but not
really the words of scripture weren't
God's focus it was still the thoughts
and the concept that's the focus but in
some vague sense inspiration still
reached the words of the biblical
writers but he cited SDA Theologian
Norman Gully who used the term God
breathed from 2 Timothy 3 to claim that
the prophets were filled with God
breathing power and wrote Faithfully
what God communicated to them in the
best words they could muster so you've
mentioned second Timothy 3 already but
can you go in a little bit more on is
this a proper use of how they're uh
appealing to God breathed here is that a
valid use of that phrase in scripture
Well it can't be because in the very
beginning of that verse it says says
every scripture is God breathed well the
word scripture is the word thean or the
is the word um when you're going into
theas of the scripture it's gra gra
means writing so the theas the god
breathed scriptures each one or every
single scripture is God
breathed it's not talking about about
the person anymore is it it's talking
about the
writing um one of the things that I
continually get confused by uh when they
created this model of
inspiration is where are you getting
this from in the texts where are you
getting this from in the Old Testament
or even the New Testament for that
matter they're trying to use second
Timothy 3 but second Timothy 3 Works
actually against them not for
them and the reason I can say that is
because I'm actually going to pull the
text up every scripture every
writing the graph the written words are
God breathed and profitable for teaching
reprove
correction and training in righteousness
so these teachings that have been given
and I think particularly Paul's probably
in that point referring to a lot of the
Old Testament texts no doubt he said he
was raised in them and trained uh in
those so it is the written text
themselves notice he didn't mention
anything about the writers no we do see
the writers are important I I've already
mention that I mentioned that in second
Peter 1 I mentioned that with Jeremiah
but remember what he said to Jeremiah I
have put my words in your mouth that's
what I've done I've I've given you my
words another concept of this I mean
when you look at Paul and I was actually
going to point this out earlier in 1
Corinthians 2 verse 13 he says these
words and we impart this in words not
taught by human wisdom but taught by the
Holy Spirit interpreting spiritual
truths to those who are spiritual but
again this in we impart this in words
not taught by wisdom it's the words that
are given to them by the Holy Spirit to
teach to instruct to uh
interpret so now you have Divine
interpreters of scripture not just those
who can teach it this is the important
of bishoping this is the important that
we believe there was a gifting that was
passed on through the hands of the
Apostles uh to be able to do this which
is what Paul's actually talking about
second Timothy 3:16 when he's talking to
a young Bishop that he left in
Ephesus right before he dies and he's
giving him instructions he's telling
them that what you've learned from me
you teach to Faithful Men the gift that
was given to you by the laying on of my
hands and the elders this is Paul's
relationship with Timothy that he is a
successor of the ministry of authority
and that they are entrusted he says
guard the deposit what is the deposit
the words it's the teachings it's the
instructions that's what they were given
Ellen White and any of these other
people are not in that succession line
This Is Why I'm an Anglican this is why
I'm a sympathizer to Rome and the
Orthodox because we are in our Bishop
descendants of the Apostles Authority we
are still under that Apostolic Authority
they have left that Authority they are
sectarian from that Authority they have
rejected the apostolic Authority in
Bishop prick that is instituted by the
apostles passed down to people like
Timothy and Titus and others that we see
there other disciples like Clement who's
mentioned in Philippians became a
successor in Rome this is why it is
important for us to look at the
scripture and what were those successors
in trusted with not a person although
they were very much elevating the
apostles and their Authority but their
teachings they left behind in the
churches well where do we find those
teachings in the text the scriptures
that Paul said all or each scripture
each graph each writing is theonas so
just the phrase every scripture every
writing is theonas disproves their
Theory yeah and we heard him mention in
the opening clip how he says they have
this charge they have to for have had to
formulate a defense for which is this
claim that they elevate Ellen White to
the level of scripture and he didn't get
into what some of those are but it's
like we're we're kind of seeing how that
works you ask the question where are
they getting this from in the text um
and there's kind of this notion at least
that I've gathered from my discussions
with them and reading their papers and
books and those sorts of things is well
no one really knows for certain what the
correct understanding is so it's kind of
just open for theories and sort of any
Theory can sort of be proposed and they
obviously this is how they elevate her
is they and demote the Bible is they've
come up with a theory of inspiration
that fits for her she's the Baseline and
then scripture is demoted by way of
saying well however it works for her is
how it must have been for the apostles
as well so it's a demotion of the
Apostles which in turn elevates her
essentially so
um just a little bit of a catch uh 22
for them heresy but go ahead yes but in
light of their whole person theory of
inspiration Lake also speaks about how
this as well as the thought model both
of these models allow for errors in the
text but that shouldn't cause one to
worry he says he cites SDA Theologian
Fernando Canal where he writes quote on
the foregoing basis we can affirm the
total reliability of scripture within
the parameters of the normal human
limitations of the thought and the
linguistic process since the whole Bible
is revealed and inspired within the
level of human thought and language it
does not represent Divine Perfection yet
its words reliably disclose God's
thoughts and will to you and will to us
this view of inspiration this whole
person model explains why certain
discrepancies and the lack of absolute
Precision in matters of detail that we
find in the phenomena of scripture do
not affect trustworthy communication of
revealed
contents Ellen White herself reflected
on the discrepancies in the Bible when
she remarked all the mistakes will not
cause trouble to One Soul or cause any
feet to stumble that would not
manufacture difficulties from the
plainest revealed truth close quote so
Stephen my question for you is scripture
inherent or does it contain lots of
mistakes and errors and if it is
inherent how can we determine
such well the scripture says a lot about
itself uh like in Psalm 19:7 the law of
the Lord is perfect converting the soul
the testimony of the Lord is sure making
the wise simple Proverbs
30:5 every word of God proves true he is
a shield to those who take refuge in him
I quoted earlier in John
17:17 sanctify them through Truth for
your word is
truth now there is a lot of sub
categories that work under
this what we believe to be divinely
inspired and absolutely true is what was
originally given in the
autographs we don't have the autographs
we have copies of the autographs we have
representations of the C those copies of
the autographs in ancient
translations like the septu for the Old
Testament so there's a lot of
subcategories in there like what what
are we saying is inspired infallible and
inherent are are we are we looking at
one single English translation are we
looking at one single Greek text are we
looking at one single Hebrew text are we
looking at one uh text for the pida are
we looking at one text uh for the old
Latin no I I don't think there's a
singular text that we can look at and
say everything in it is perfect um so I
just want to clarify that from the
beginning but I do believe that God's
perfect word has been preserved in the
body of manuscripts whether you're
talking the old or new testament uh I
think the due diligence is on our part
to find discover and to uh do our work
to demonstrate what would have been
represented in those sections of
disagreement the original text but as it
sits as it sits the very words of God
themselves are true uh its prophecies
are true its predictions are true I was
just recently listening to my co-host do
a he he delivered the homy in Luke's
gospel on Jesus's
sermon known as the oliv it discourse
and it was part of the Le lexal reading
for that Sunday and he demonstrated how
Jesus in the prediction uh Wars rumors
of wars Nation Rise Against Nation
pestilence and all these things he
demonstrated historically from Josephus
and from eus and other historians where
events that Jesus predicted happened
happened exactly how they said why
because the word of God is true Jesus is
a faithful and true teacher and he was a
faithful and true Prophet so when we get
into these discussions I'd like to know
where they believe that the Bible is
actually wrong um and maybe it's not the
Bible That's wrong it's maybe their
understanding of the Bible is wrong uh
but what examples what passages are they
saying or Inc correct because when
Daniel looked back at Jeremiah's
prophecies he didn't go well he got most
of it right at least uh no he said wow
you know this is exactly what was said
Jesus speaking about the law and the
prophets he said not a jot or tit not a
jot or tit will pass until all is
fulfilled he believed that the words of
the teachings of scripture would be
fulfilled to the very small punctual
sections that that he was going to bring
a completion not not destroy the law of
the prophets but to fulfill them in
order to fulfill them they have to be
true so he believed that the law and the
prophets spoke truth and that he was
going to bring the consummated
fulfillment of those things so this
works against the theology that we see
in scripture as it sees itself as a book
of perfection and narcy it's divinely
inspired and if it can be wrong then God
can be wrong because if they're his
words then he is either fallible or
infallible um and we believe when God
spoke he spoke
truth again there's a lot of
subcategories to that as we get into the
manuscript disc discussion but as it
sits the word of God is true and I don't
see any examples that they've given in
any of this that are worth paying
attention to to say
differently yeah maybe we could have a
textual uh critical discussion sometime
I know that that might bore a lot of
people in our audience because it's not
necessarily the most glamorous topic but
it is one of personal interest for me um
and I think you you did it it well there
that um normatively speaking when we're
talking about inherency we're talking
about the autographa the the the
original manuscripts and uh that
oftentimes produces a whole snowball of
questions that people may end up having
so maybe we can do a uh a stream on that
sometime in the future but um they will
never accept
inherency because Ellen White's writings
are full of Errors so everything has to
be understood in light of the bar that
she sets any standard that eliminates
her or disqualifies her will be said to
be too rigid they love using that word
as we've seen numerous times they use it
as a pive in the context of this
discussion but to close us out now I
want to test Ellen White's alleged
inspiration against scripture so here's
my central proposition this is my
syllogism if you will is that if two
things are divinely revealed as well as
divinely inspired So Divine Revelation
not confusing Revelation with
inspiration but if two things are
divinely revealed as well as divinely
inspired then the two things cannot
contradict each other as late claimed in
the opening clip they assert that Ellen
White gives further Revelation from God
that is non-canonical and this
Revelation came after the closing of the
biblical Canon which means that if a
piece of alleged Divine Revel
given to Ellen White contradicts
scripture a previous divine revelation
then that would call into question her
divinely inspired status and she would
simultaneously fail the biblical test of
a prophet so the first test little bit
of a lead up here but I want to make
sure you get the point and that it's
clear as well for the audience before I
ask my
question earlier I showed how she
claimed that the Holy Spirit authored
both her writings and the Bible if if
this is correct then there shouldn't be
anything in her writings that
contradicts scripture she herself even
recognized such in Patriarchs and
Prophets where she claimed that whatever
contradicts God's word we can be sure
proceeds from Satan so let's test
this in spiritual gifts volume 3 she
wrote
quote the Lord first established the
system of sacrificial offerings with
Adam after his fall which he taught to
his descendants this system was
corrupted Before the Flood by those who
separated themselves from the faithful
followers of God and engaged in the
building of the Tower of Babel they
sacrificed to gods of their own making
instead of the god of Heaven close quote
so she contradicts the Bible which
clearly shows that the Tower of Babel
was built After the flood not before
it yet in Patriarchs and Prophets The
Same Book she said whatever contradicts
God's word we may be sure uh proceeds
from Satan she also had this to say
about the tower the Tower of Babel quote
the Dwellers on the plane of Shar
disbelieved God's covenant that he would
not again bring a flood upon the Earth
many of them denied the existence of God
and attributed the flood to the
operation of natural causes others
believed in a Supreme Being and that it
was he who had destroyed the anti-
deluvian world and their hearts like
that of Cain rose up in Rebellion
against him one object before them in
the erection of the Tower was to secure
their own safety in case of another
Deluge by carrying the structure to a
much greater height than was reached By
the Waters of the flood they thought to
place themselves beyond all possibility
of danger and as they would be able to
ascend to the region of the clouds they
hoped to ascertain the cause of the
flood the whole undertaking was designed
to exalt still further the pride of its
projectors and to turn the minds of
future Generations away from God and
leave them into idolatry close quote so
here she claims the Tower of Babel was
built After the flood in fear of a
second one to try and Ascend to the
heavens and ascertain why the first
flood actually happened and just so
people
understand she claimed what is contained
in Patriarchs and Prophets not just
Patriarchs and Prophets but what's
contained in Patriarchs and Prophets is
allegedly barricaded by a thus saith the
Lord and are truths that were traced
upon her heart and mind no different
then the decalog was traced onto Stone
by the Finger of God so Dr Boyce what we
read from her is supposed to be inspired
Revelation from God and she claimed to
be shown by God that the world leading
up to the flood was corrupted by those
who had separated themselves from the
true followers of God and engaged in
building the Tower of Babel only one
major problem again the Tower of Babel
was built After the flood in Genesis 11
does a contradiction like this
disqualify someone's writings from being
divinely inspired
yeah because she's if she was writing it
um I I cannot help but to
compare this view that she has of
herself and others of her to what's
considered in Roman Catholicism ex
cathedra uh I I don't know how familiar
uh your audiences with the term ex
cathedra ex cathedra is when the the
from the chair it's when the pope speaks
there's times when the pope speaks and
he's in ER he can be an error and
there's been a lot of Errors coming from
the sea of Peter at times but then
there's certain circumstances where he
is speaking as the Vicor of God the
Vicor of Christ and he is speaking truth
that is
infallible I find it ironic the reason I
bring this
up is that these Church groups these
movements like the 7-Day Advent have
have tried
to slam Rome and I think you and I uh
correct me if I'm wrong here miles I'm
pretty sure last time we talked on this
didn't we have a discussion about uh
their abhorrence for Roman influence and
the change over the years and stuff that
there's this natural combative towards
Rome yeah we talked about uh
restorationism versus Reformation right
yeah that that was that was us yeah I I
I thought that was you I was pretty sure
what's interesting is that they have
their own setup of ex
cathedr uh while they uphor Roman
practice and Roman Authority they have
actually instituted a replica so you
talk about stealing um and copying they
have set up their own papacy with this
person they have set up their own ex
cathedra uh the difference is it was
Peter in Matthew 16 where it was stated
did on this rock I will build my church
and he was referring to Peter there and
the gates of Hades will not Prevail and
you will be given the keys to the
kingdom and that what you bind on Earth
will be bound in heaven what you loose
on Earth will be loose in heaven so we
have in Divine scripture definitely the
Sea of Peter having the authority of
binding and loosening we also see later
in John 20 gives all of his Apostles the
power to forgive sin on Earth and what
is Forgiven Earth will be forgiven in
heaven whatever is not forgiven on Earth
will not be forgiven in heaven that's
power that's Authority that was not
given to anybody but the apostles but
the Sea of
Peter was given the Keys of the Kingdom
to do the power of binding and
loosening and it is interesting that
these teachers that these proclamations
from the Seven Day Advent going back to
Ellen White have rejected and and and
absolutely um
criticize on a major level these groups
like the Roman
Catholics for their Corruptions and
missteps and wrong authorities yet
they're actually attached to Peter
because they're actually in Peter's
church now whether you're not you agree
with that is irrelevant my point is to
show the comparison here that Ellen
White has within 7-Day adventism set up
an institution no different than the
institution they claim to hate I
actually have a couple of comparisons
I'd love to share and actually put these
down if you look at the contradictions
between them but there are similarities
but here's where the contradictions come
in ex cathedra again ex cathedra is the
authority comes from the pope who's from
the chair successor of Peter exercising
Christ's teaching through the
magisterium that's a whole another ball
game now Ellen White on the other hand
the authority comes directly from God
through
vision um bypassing any hierarchical
church succession uh Divine councel uh
Universal councel none of that just
direct direct communication which even
the apostles themselves and their
successors didn't always have
functionally how about infallibility ex
Cathedral believes in absolute
infallibility when teaching on faith and
morals under specific conditions now
there are times um now you tell me if
I'm wrong about this uh it seemed like
there's some contradictory in the
Seventh Day Adventist where she would
deny personal infallibility but others
would claim it for her now you tell me
if I'm wrong you've been studying this
longer than me are there not times where
there seems to be some contradictory on
who like you know her
infallibility absolutely um now I could
show you obviously um numerous
statements from the organization so
official Source documentation that
outright states that she was infallible
you're going to get a lot of seventh
though that say no no no we don't claim
she's infallible and then you just
basically have to ask them where did she
essentially air and they don't typically
want to go down that path some will um
the Tower of Babel is actually one that
a lot of them are actually willing to
recognize but um yes I'm not aware of
anywhere that Ellen White herself
verbatim stated that she was infallible
though I can show you plenty a plethora
of statements from the organization
itself giving her such a status like we
essentially saw in the statement of
confidence even though they don't use
that term and would they say that she
received that infallibility from these
prophetic Visions uh where would they
say that infallibility came from
directly that's an interesting question
um more than likely they're going to say
and Lake actually talks about this a
little bit in his book um it's going to
essentially be I would guess don't hold
me to this but my my guess would be that
they would say something along the lines
of it comes by way of the fact that it
it's attached to Revelation so on that
on that horizontal level of revelation
um it is coming by way of the source
through which the Revelation is coming
so so because all of this stuff again in
that statement of confidence they don't
delineate like a lot of Adventists do
where they try and do this sort of like
well it's only her conflict of the ages
series it's just those books no that's
not what the statement of confidence in
her writing says the statement of
confidence in her
writings is talking about the whole
gamut of writings not this hierarchy
where C C writings have more Authority
than other ones no they claim like they
said there's no degrees of inspiration
and they don't believe essentially that
like certain books of hers are more
inspired than another Etc no it's it's
the whole lot of stuff and would they
say and I'm asking questions out loud
because I I'm pretty sure we're on the
same page and the same anwers I just
want the audience to to see the
similarities I'm going to build here
would they say uh that her teachings
have the power to dictate things that
should and should not happen with
consequences or no consequences within
the 7-Day Adventist Church oh of course
I mean she has a whole uh large volume
set of books titled testimonies for the
church which is for the Seventh
Adventist Church with all sorts of
warnings if you don't listen and all
this sort of stuff which is explicit
hers is contextually to the Seven Day
Adventist doesn't speak outside of it as
much as within it okay uh how about
structure um supported by Congregational
Church
structure uh her Authority came through
direct inspiration not through any kind
of hierarchy or or any kind of uh Divine
counsil but my point that I'm bringing
to all this is that if you look at
everything that you just
said all of that is a replica of the
Roman Catholic church with the Sea of
Peter with papacy with ex cathedra and
with binding and loosening and bringing
in in and getting rid of things and
putting law in place canon law in place
the difference is the difference is is
that the Roman Catholic church has a
2,000 year old system that can be traced
to Peter and that its successors do make
mistakes just like Peter Peter made
mistakes all the time he had to be
rebuked to the face by Paul um after
being given that proclamation in Matthew
16 Jesus said get behind me Satan I mean
like I mean so you know Peter made
mistakes he was fallible
but there were times where words like
flesh and blood didn't reveal this to
you but my Father which is in heaven did
so there are times where he's fallible
and infallible but the difference is is
that the institution of the Roman
Catholic Church actually has grounds for
their claim they actually have
historical evidence they have ecumenical
council they have direct canon law they
have fulfilled proclamations of popes on
the other hand she just came out of thin
air no lineage no Divine counsel no
connectivity to the apostles no
connectivity to their churches no
connectivity to their writings and and
it is a
self self exalted papacy is what it is
whether they want to believe that or not
they have done exactly what Rome does
that they hate the difference is they
did it disconnected from anything
Apostolic Rome is actually doing it
while they sit in the Vatican with
Peter's bones in their tomb Paul's bones
in one of their Cathedral the apostles
bones and all them still there they have
records they have evidence they have
bodies and they have reason and location
to stand behind their claims I'm not
here to defend Roman Catholicism I'm
Anglican all I'm saying is the two
systems the two systems are identical
one has historical roots with evidence
archaeological
historically written and oral and the
other one came out of thin air out of
the middle of nowhere where this nobody
connected to no one is all of a sudden
given all these Divine Inspirations and
they have simply created a new Roman
Catholic institution with no stability
no historicity that's all it is whether
they want to believe that or not they've
created their own ex
Cathedral yeah um one thing I will
correct just because I know Adventist
will latch on to it and that'll become
the whole focus of all things um they're
not congregational um they they claim to
hold a presbyterian form of church
governance um I'm going to not open up
that can of worms being a presbyterian
um but spoiler alert no um they're
they're not um but exactly like you said
it's just and that's we kind of talked
about that the last time you're were
here that's one of the big differences
between restoration and
Reformation let me clarify when I say
congregational in the sense of like the
authority is over the congregation like
that these Canon laws are for the
congregation just like the church is
expected when they they come into
communion with uh either the Anglican
Church I mean you're affirming things
you're affirming the 39 articles you're
affirming like you're coming under the
authority of the bishop prick it's so
different I mean they they have
authority figures too and the
congregation has to be led by those laws
or or or whatever they call them they
may not call them canon law whatever
testimonies or whatever you said they
were they have to put themselves under
something so the congregation is led by
some sort of authority to me it's no
different they just set up a a mini mini
roome that's all they did yeah except
they've actually gone one step further
because they're a little bit more bold
in my opinion in this area than than
Rome has been um the the papal seat has
only spoken ex cathedra uh two times I
believe two or three times right in all
of history whereas essentially Ellen
White's uh entire volume of works is ex
cathedr you're talking millions of words
she claimed to have over 2,000
Visions these are all divinely inspired
divinely inspired she's the last human
being to supposedly talk face to face
with Jesus and what she thought to ask
him when she saw him was does your
father have a form like you do and the
Adventist Jesus told Ellen White that
God the father has a physical body like
we
do we could
go ahead yeah just just to clarify I
think we two times universally ex
Cathedral has been exercise since the
first Vatican Council was in 1870 that
was for the Immaculate Conception of
Mary and the bodily assumption bily
assumption yeah so but yeah it's not
like it was every time the pope got up
and said something it was ex Cathedral
or something right and it went through a
magisterium too it wasn't
just his final Proclamation was that of
ex cathedra but it was not just him
sitting in a like you said here it was
actually a order of Cardinals and
Bishops who had discussed researched
defined talked prayed meditated repeated
debated then there was a proclamation of
X cathedra um that that ended with the
Pope's Proclamation but it wasn't him
independent either
um whereas in her case I don't see any
evidence where she was working with a
councel working with a governing body uh
the way that we see Rome do it so again
hers is private
Revelation with private interpretation
which is the opposite of what Peter said
was given that no prophecy was given
from private interpretation to me it's a
major contradictory major
contradict yeah and just again to to set
the record um we're not Roman Catholic
apologists um that anytime I mention
anytime I mention Rome you know I get
lambasted by Adventist of I'm a Jesuit
and I'm it's like folks you need to
represent people accurately you just
because you represent somebody
accurately doesn't mean you're now an
apologist for them I'm just an apologist
for representing people accurately and
so that that's we're just
comparing yeah the point is we're
comparing like you hate the system but
you actually have mimicked it um and
you've Mimi it mimicked it without any
substantial history you've mimicked it
without any lineage they have more
reason to whether you like him or not
they have more reason to have the belief
that they've done this and they have
these athor authoritative powers and
they have because they're they're in the
sea of Peter they're at the very Vatican
itself they have the body of Peter they
have the body of Paul they have like
they have the relics they have the icons
they have the inscriptions they have
Paul's chains that he was chained in his
prison cell with they have all of these
things so if there is a church that has
the right to actually claim to be
speaking that authoritatively they have
all the evidence and reason for for that
argument a woman out of nowhere
connected to no one with no spiritual
lineage is the most
unlikely person that can speak with this
kind of authority because it is so
disconnected from Biblical Authority
it's so disconnected from the life of
Jesus the apostles their successors and
that is a major major flaw in the system
from the beginning and even if they want
to try and demotor down to like a
reformer which I've I've heard some of
them do it's like well well no because
again this is the difference between
reformation and restoration yes these
restorationists are just you're not even
connected to the church at all I
understand some of the complaints that
you know my Roman cathol friends
Orthodox friends Etc have about
protestantism Etc but one thing you
can't argue is there's a a vast
difference between people that are Roman
clerics who are seeking to then bring
about change within something they're
actually affiliated with versus a bunch
of anti-trinitarian anti-gospel
Heretics with no connection to the
church in history just up and rising up
and saying well God gave us a word
through this woman that were supposed to
restore his church and we're his last
day people and Revelation 12 proves it
it's it's a a very different the
reformers like Luther still had Bishops
he brought he was a succession priest I
mean he's he was under orders of Peter
as a priest he was a monk uh he worked
as a monk under Divine orders of the Sea
of Peter he brought and converted uh
Bishops that became a part of the
Lutheran tradition Even Calvin at the
end of his life in Geneva was
corresponding back and forth with
anglicans remember a lot of anglicans
went to Geneva for Refuge
uh when Mary went nuts in England uh and
so when you when you look at that he was
ready to start opening the discussion of
bringing the bishop prick back into
Geneva why because he saw the historical
necessity to be connected to the
authority of those who are attached to
the hands- on head and the pouring of
oil and the praying over and the gifting
of bishops from the apostles to their
successors so even the reformers were
willing to act I think I I'm convinced
based on the end of Calvin's life if he
lived another five years he'd have
brought the Bishop Rick back into Geneva
uh Luther already had it uh and so the
the anglicans had it so again the the
they're in another category they can lik
themselves or liking her another
reformer so far removed from the church
from where they were uh Luther saw Rome
as the true church he just saw as a good
church that was going bad he didn't see
it as a fa he believed that that was the
Sea of Peter it just hence it needed
reforming not
removing yep one final example
here so Stephen adventism has an entire
set of doctrines around food that they
call their health
message essentially the idea that one
must be a vegetarian in order to be fit
for heaven they claimed that Adam and
Eden was a vegetarian and since Heaven
is a Return to Eden they conclude that
you need to get prepared for that now or
you won't be fit to exist there this of
course was supported by Ellen White she
had a Health Vision and her handling of
the Bible where um she would read
various texts in light of that
presupposition so one such example of
this the the presupposition of the
health message being true and this
Vision being from God Etc one such
example is the story of Daniel and his
friends in Daniel 1 so commenting on
Daniel 1 she writes quote
Daniel purposed in his heart that he
would not defile himself with the
portion of the king's meat nor with the
wine which he drank therefore he
requested of the prince of the Unix that
he might not defile himself
daniel8 this request was not preferred
in a defiant Spirit but was solicited as
a great favor Daniel and his companions
were courteous kind respectful
possessing the grace of meekness and
modesty and now as Daniel and his
fellows were brought to the T test they
placed themselves fully on the side of
righteousness and Truth they did not
move capriciously but
intelligently they decided that as flesh
meat had not composed their diet in the
past neither should it come into their
diet in the future and as the use of
wine had been prohibited to all those
who should engage in the service of God
they determined that they would not
partake of it close
quote this is to say that Daniel was
allegedly a vegetarian flesh meat of any
kind had never composed his diet in the
past present or future she said not just
unclean Meats Adventist but all meats
and this is supposed to be a divinely
inspired statement from God the Holy
Spirit except Daniel as a faithful Jew
would have partaken of the Passover Lamb
as was as was commanded in Exodus 12
3-8 furthermore Daniel 10 clearly tells
us that Daniel was fast from meat and
wine at one point in his life well to
fast from something by definition would
mean that you have to have partaken of
the thing that you're voluntarily
abstaining from for a season otherwise
you wouldn't be fasting from it and the
avenus biblical Research Institute even
recognized such where in an article
titled Daniel 103 was Daniel a
vegetarian anel Rodriguez who's the
former director of the Bri wrote that in
this particular setting Daniel fasted
for meat but when he was in charge of
his own diet he followed the levitical
regulations which included clean Meats
Daniel 10:3 which is a tacit admission
that no Daniel was not a
vegetarian so Ellen White contradicts
the biblical text again yet both her
claim and the Bible are supposed to be
Revelation from God and equally as
inspired if we take issue with this the
charges that were being too rigid and
were holding Ellen White on too high of
a standard
what is your take on this contradiction
and does it call into question Ellen
White being inspired yeah uh for a
couple reasons one um the word meat
there is the word path bag in Hebrew and
it is
not simply rendered meat it it simply
means portion of food or dainty I mean
it could it could have multiple and the
reason I think that it could be
reasonable to reject it to Simply mean
actual flesh I I mean it could apply to
that that's not the direct
interpretation of it but if we actually
go to the septu agent for example uh
when we look at the translation of it I
was actually going to pull it up I think
it's trapid it is yes trapid is the word
here which is often used to refer to a
table in fact the term is used for a
counter or a place where Brokers met for
loans or to give interest or or some
sort of money they would come to the
table and they would receive a benefit
uh of a
loan and so when you look at the septu
aent Translating that section they
actually just translated the king's
table it wasn't it seemed like the text
could indicate that meat was there
because they ate certain kinds of
herbs but I don't think it was just the
meat that was rejected and obviously
that wasn't the point because it was
also wine and everybody wanted to focus
on the meat here but he also refused the
King's
Wine uh God gave his people the most
Bountiful Vineyards to enjoy the wine in
fact uh Proverbs Ecclesiastes talk about
drink your wine with joy uh God is given
this to you he's delighted in you drink
your wine with joy so
obviously it wasn't the wine that was
the
problem um it wasn't even the meat that
was the problem I don't even think it
was about the meat I think it was the
meal portions that the King was giving
meat was probably a section of that meal
but it would have been other items with
it it's the fact that the king had a
defiling meal in front of them that was
probably filled with
uncleanliness and it was filled with all
the
dainties of being in a kingdom and they
did not want to feel like they were a
part of a pagan Kingdom they wanted to
live and have a diet like Exiles because
that's who they were they were Exiles
they wanted to feel like
Exiles and and the King was trying to
acclimate them into the culture and
acclimate them into uh because this is
what would happen you take the wise and
the handsome young people and you
brainwash them that's what you do that's
how you control them that's how you
change their culture and adapt it into
yours and they're refusing not a single
item on the menu they're refusing the
whole thing they refuse to pray to the
gods we see later in Daniel 3 they
refuse to bow to uh people who
proclaimed themselves as gods they
refuse all the dainties of the Kingdom
that would impact them to become
acclimated to this culture rather than
to feel like the exile that they really
were that's the point of the text even
the Hebrew word itself is is hardly even
talking about meat in itself so about
dainties or portions and the sepian
obviously understood the Hebrew word to
be that because they translated it as
table and that would indicate an
entirety of a meal put in front of you
so I I think this is ridiculous argument
so you're telling me that the point of
Daniel 1 is not to teach us that God
desires for us to have a vegetarian
lifestyle that's exactly what I'm saying
brother thank you so much for being here
let people know where they can find more
of your content before we shut things
down I have your channel your YouTube
channel linked uh down below but if you
have any other link that you want me to
post there as well just get that to me
uh
offline yeah yeah so uh we're fairly new
on YouTube just started YouTube this
year um most everything that we put out
prior to this year the last two years
before is on your major platforms for
podcast Spotify Apple podbean Google
podcast there's seven of them out there
a lot of people listen on different
platforms uh I'm pretty sure apple and
uh Spotify are the biggest ones so you
can find us on there it's facts fcts
it's an acronym that was mentioned um
the logo is going let's see if I can get
in the camera it's going to look
something like that it's got the
Jerusalem cross on it um and stands for
Father's apoc Canon text and scripture
that's what it'll look like uh when you
look it up on your favorite platform uh
so yeah we're definitely bigger on the
podcast side but we're trying to get the
YouTube side going this year it's our
first year I think we started back in
March uh we actually took over a channel
for apolog Ministry that that uh didn't
work through uh we have a Board of
Trustees I'm actually meeting with them
in a few weeks uh to go over the new
plan for
2025 and uh you can find me on social
media Twitter uh hardly ever use
Instagram uh Facebook and uh you know I
do a lot of different work for different
Ministries I'm on a lot of different
channels you can just put my name in
YouTube and you'll find me on a plethora
of channels uh doing discussions like
this so uh be sure to check any of that
out and uh like And subscribe us on the
channels that we do show and um if you
want I can send you a link for the
Spotify and apple to add in there as
well so people that like to listen on
the podcast side can follow along that
way as well
that would be excellent and may God
continue to grow your guys' efforts you
are doing uh excellent work man I really
appreciate uh not just your time but the
work that you're putting in in the areas
that you are so may God continue to give
increase there I'm grateful as well for
you the viewer thank you for being here
as always um May Christ richly bless you
in the grace and peace won by him and
his vicarious death on the cross for
Sinners until next time God bless
[Music]